[Music]
I am
blue hey is the big man in high rollers
take sis but fair warning he does not
like to be bothered when he's on a hot
streak oh my God what a Hey
Howard you how's business well you know
the world's falling apart and I'm
running a casino things are great and
speaking of great waitress could you
bring us some small bites for the
reflective woman over here or do you
just eat
megabytes let me me tell you one of my
favorite youu tide
stories ales all around Chin
Chin
are oh got to admit that's some solid
holiday word
[Music]
play there are infinite stories to be
told across the
[Applause]
Multiverse well you got the color of the
suit right I'm Santa Claus
[Applause]
[Music]
baby